[Music]
foreign
there's a monster outside
what you people discovered is bigger
than we ever thought possible how big is
that thing what's the largest shark that
ever existed
a living fossil thought to have been
extinct oh
wrong
oh my God
let's Megalodon
he's kidding right
[Music]
nothing's out there you need to find it
and kill it why don't you just put a
tracker on it
did you guys ever watch Shark Week
[Music]
he looks heroic but he's kind of got a
negative attitude
[Music]
I'm dating with the future of the planet
I'm the necessary shop to the system
I am human evolutionary change
[Music]
bulletproof
superhuman who the hell are you
bad guy
the mission has been compromised
we need help
[Music]
our Target's name is Brixton he's a
ghost
we're gonna need the best trackers in
the business Luke Hobbs on what you call
an ice cold can of whoop ass
career law man always gets his guy
we're gonna need to operate outside the
system Deckard Shaw and what you might
call a champagne problem
Rogue former MI6 agent doesn't play well
with others if we stand a chance against
Brixton you guys have to work together
no way
this job
requires stealth
[Applause]
I need you I'm trying to save the world
which for the record will be my fourth
time
because I'm really good at it you have
no idea what we're dealing with
Hops and sure
you've gone
remember me
sure one two three
thank you
[Music]
three shocks will kill a man there we go
the bad guys [__]
you had to rub your big mouth didn't you
huh yeah I thought it was a cool thing
to say at the moment
as a private contractor you possess a
unique set of skills
foreign
[Music]
I said the front was clear
ah front back right wrong anyway shall
we I have another job for you so what we
got Greg Simmons the billionaire arms
dealer oh a lot very serious faces up
here and there you can't catch this fish
with conventional lures I'm sorry The
Lure being Danny Francesco
the movie star Greg Simmons favorite
movie star and how do we get him
blackmail
who's the guy very good carry on
the world needs you for your greatest
role yet who are you I'm your new
manager there's a sensitive and awkward
situation between you and your
sister-in-law I actually love my
sister-in-law
he made that quite evident
[Music]
no reason to be nurse they're all the
killers
you're an actor
when someone pinch me please is that
Danny Francesca what's next for you I'm
playing a mysterious self-made
billionaire he just described me shadow
me do whatever I do whatever I do
whoever Greg was buying from I was
amongst you last night
I can get inside of them
I hope you take them to dinner first
before you get inside of them
sexually
what happens he recognized your awesome
fortune that is a sexy name covers blown
what do I do the movie star's gonna melt
she stopped any Francesca
you let me worry about that
what are you gonna do with that I'm
gonna shoot at them Danny
oh
so you weren't seen by anyone yes that's
a yes to one seen by anyone yes or yes
you were seen by someone yes
and today is the day that I die
I'm getting a little ahead of myself
I've been poisoned with some kind of
Chinese synthetic you've got to do
something for me dog they gave you the
Beijing cocktail it's cutting off your
adrenaline if you stop you died
say goodbye to my girl and go out with a
little style all I have to do is stay
alive long enough to make it happen
clear
with the wrong I don't know where it is
you're so stressed out what's the matter
I need to tell you something I'm a
professional head man if you're gonna
break up with me at least you can tell
me the truth though wait
no come on
your whole crew is history
the unidentified Man Behind today's
Mayhem is making its last stand
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen we have a new
addition H
but it goes security specializing cash
trucks across L.A
do you have any idea how dangerous this
job can be
yeah we ain't the Predators with a prey
you ready ready
this is your temporary sidearm pistols
in a machine do you have a problem I
don't know do I
a 10 grand drop you should have been
back five minutes ago
they're serious
leave this to me
time
sorry pal
ette
it doesn't feel right
[Music]
it's like he wants trucks to get hit
he's not a cop
but if it's not a cop what is he
a while back we lost two cards civilian
two there was an investigation
we still haven't found a scam that did
it
you're in an accident
he didn't make it I need to know I
killed my son
tree has been Shook and it's been shook
hard
we've scorched the Earth
boy you started by trying to do anything
but what I'm hearing is you think you've
done everything
I can see it's gonna be a long night
It's gotta be an inside job
I can go in two weeks
you only wish you could do in 20 years
garage
you good
we're being hunted so this was going to
be a street fight oh that is
[Music]
if you want to glimpse of the future I
have to slip behind you you can't outrun
the person
this is a world that doesn't play by
your rules
you and your friends are a part of it
now
let's do this
[Music]
I don't have friends I got family
my boss said you're the man for the job
but unavailable
you have 10 seconds to change your mind
I'll give you five seconds to remove
your hand
all right
[Music]
I'm the system using only the best man
for this assignment don't think of this
as just another job think of it as I'm a
mission one condition I drive my own car
if you change the oil gave it a tune-up
took out all the non-essentials I
learned my company
want to tell me what this is all about
when you pass 75 feet from the car
complete the mission save your life
[Music]
you didn't mention your brain company
it's
complicated with you it's always
complicated
they're going to kill us
not you really should be more positive
step away
from the vehicle you've disappointed me
I've been thinking any idiot with a
driver's license will do
you're fired Jason Statham you think
we're playing games Frank a little late
for warnings don't you think
oh
one more step Frank
come on one more
[Music]
transporter three
two another successful Mission I can do
what I do without you in my earpiece
head down the tunnel you got three
coming in
you imagine me as a spot with a gun what
these look delicious
this is very chewy you're eating a hand
towel
just uh cleansing my palette
you want to joined the CIA I thought it
was going to be this amazing spy I'm
just the same boring person I was before
you play it too safe I just hear my
mom's voice give up on your dreams Susan
just to write that in My Lunchbox
Reina boyanov is about to sell a
tactical nuclear weapon to a terrorist
organization I told you to send me in
there you can't she knows the identity
of all our agents we need someone to
find a bomb without being detected I'll
do it okay thanks lunch lady you're
going okay
yeah bring one of your cats as a
sidekick I don't have cats
go see Patrick he's got special
equipment for you take a future
you'll be given a new identity oh cat
lady just missing a shirt that says I've
never felt the touch of a man
it's a confidence Builder
you really think you're ready for the
field leave the actions in mind
damn it
damn
you are not to make direct contact with
any of the targets you are incredibly
out of your league
while I was on fire not the car I was on
fire I'm starting to freak me out
four little pathetic Susan my father
used to bring people here did he also
make you dress like a [__] dolphin
trainer
did I forget to knock
who are you you want me to have Jackie
and Lacey explain it to you Cagney's
gonna come up your ass like a
thunderbolt and show off onto your
Swedish meatballs you're gonna cry I'm
not gonna cry you're crying now I'm not
let's go
[Music]
they're loaded
thank you
good
and I Pronounce You Man a knife
[Music]
foreign
I'm back
you can't let the contents of that seed
fall into the wrong hands
what's the plan sure I can find them
kill them
how did you do that okay
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
the only man who knew the combination
Tony do something terrible
[Music]
shut up and sit down you big balls so
what should I fight you can call me
Susan if it makes you happy I don't care
if it's Muhammad Ahmad Bruce Lee you're
going down in the fourth round
whoops
[Music]
anything to declare yeah don't go to
England
did you understand
[Applause]
Daddy come by we'll have some breakfast
it'll be a long trip I'm in Venice learn
the language of poetry art romance sex
I'm like you my friend I don't need a
guidebook the plan was Flawless the next
45 minutes we own this place gentlemen
okay Steve it's right above you the
heist was perfect
the Escape was clean
what are you gonna do with your chair
I'm gonna get a 9277 with the 70 watt
amps and Burr Brown dacs it's a big
stereo speak
they blow women's clothes off the only
threat
never saw coming what the hell are you
doing if he plans my own somewhere you
can go we won't find you it's probably
right John
this summer I found him Stella it's in
Los Angeles stealing that gold is not
gonna be farther back it's not about the
gold John was like a father to me too
and I just can't move on so I've said
things right
they're not in it for the pay hey Steve
gang's all here you have no idea how
hard it is for me not to reach across
this table and kill you you want to
start the game up again that's fine with
me they're in it
for the payback come on you'll try to
think how my guards I have five of them
that you don't know about I don't do
dogs I had real bad experience what
happened I had a bad experience we tried
to hack the system you ready to create
the biggest traffic jam in the history
of Los Angeles I'm so ready
oops you're gonna try to crack my safe
you took my father for me I'm taking
this
they just blew the best thing you had
going for you just blew the element of
surprise
surprised why do you get to punch him
and I don't Paramount Pictures presents
the colds come to us gridlock every
route except for the one we choose force
that truck to go exactly where we wanted
to go before
they hit the streets sick guys
made our play and I came out on top so
if you want to say it's over five
seconds your paint on the train
Mark Wahlberg Charlize Theron Edward
Norton Seth Green Jason Statham Moe's
death and Donald sutherman
you're out of moves the game is over
just give up already
no imagination
what happened to my truck
got them
Holy Spirit The Italian Job you know
this is never about the gold whatever
helps you sleep at night sweetheart
in the New York City underworld there
are gangsters
killers and corrupt cops but today
the most wanted person in the city
12 year old girl
right
you want to tell me why those made
around to you I can memorize anything
they showed me a very long number is
there anything interesting to you about
it's not just random there's a sequence
who took the girl it was Luke Wright
what
looked right the Big Apple's hardest cut
Once Upon a Time
got everybody on this Chinese close
every exit out of Manhattan
that girl does not leave this city
let's go to war
[Music]
are we safe
I got the numbers now you're dealing
with me
[Music]
you got some balls Luke amazing I can
even walk
Ed together
it's a once in a lifetime opportunity
Terry because we can't sit up we are not
Frank Brothers maybe that's why we could
get away with it
but have you been in a bag and let's go
[Music]
this last night we're trying to home in
on a 300 000 pound bank rate 300 Grand
more like 3 million
holy [__] you know it is
well we're in the crapper Jerry it was
in my safety deposit problems
photographs of a certain royal princess
sophisticated This calamity by storing
your blackmail materials in this Bank
if we don't get onto the case quickly
God knows what will happen to our
photographs so you want me to come up
with something before it's any
accountability for anyone we'd welcome
suggestions
absolutely professional criminals
you get all your nasty pictures you get
Indemnity and we want it signed sealed
and delivered by a public figure how
about the Prime Minister yeah
sorry Dave
[Music]
man
thank you people call us that beyond our
back they're not going to say it to your
face are they well you just bloody dude
[Music]
I've seen this face before he's an in
painful
[Music]
what I do requires a certain mindset
I do assignments designated targets some
jumps need to look like accidents
best jobs are the ones nobody ever knows
you were there
[Applause]
[Music]
I know I'm better than you you know
you're a damn machine
[Applause]
you need someone to watch your back this
wouldn't be about Stephen uh would it
he's your son damn disappointment always
has been always will be
Harry McKenna sold this company out
there must be a mistake you know how
this company Works Mr Bishop he had to
be removed
[Music]
sorry about your father it was the loss
for both of us
I want to know what you know go online
it's all on the internet but I don't
want to read it I want to do it oh man
you know what a mechanic is a Hitman
another take your training to the next
level
so what's the plan now time to finish
the job
pretty impressive huh
those were my best teams I guess I'll
have to send more
save the fuel we're coming for you
and you can get to me before I get to
you
already have
do it
[Music]
thank you
civilized people need to follow rules
and these are mine
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't steal from people who can't
afford it I don't have people that don't
deserve it so relax
I gotta say Parker he came as advertised
but I'm gonna need the whole score for
this next thing he made a deal
if you were me what would you do with a
guy like you
'd kill him while I had the chance
most importantly if you say you'll do
something and you don't do it
I'll make sure you regret it
he's got connections give me a name
someone on the inside it's Rogers
San Antonio Texas
is Daniel permit your real name why
wouldn't it be
because you're less than two months old
I don't know what you're into but
whatever it is you're gonna need
somebody who knows the territory take
off your clothes what I have to know if
you were in a wire
don't ask me any questions because I'm
only going to tell you what I want to
tell him people took something from me
I'm just gonna put things right who the
hell are you
Parker
he's alive
Parker's dead you shot him right
[Music]
they're here for a rubber in they're
going to use their house to lay low when
they're done
score of a lifetime so let them steal
something you steal it from them and I
get a cut
I always follow through always
[Music]
how do you sleep at night
I'm gonna drink coffee after seven
[Music]
just having fun
I won't touch her again
[Music]
it worked
Nick she loves me then
one thousand dollars
can you tell me about yourself you want
my qualifications along those lines
those lights
I can take care of things that's so easy
to know
like a one thousand dollar chip
clocks right into my shoulder now I need
500 000 to buy me five years right now
I'm only short 499 500. I like Blackjack
good maybe more than I should
have eaten
hey Nick
a fighter
you did what he did
I want my revenge Nikki
spider guy his name is Danny Demarco
do me something to watch but now I need
you to do me something do not mess with
these guys
yeah
remember me
do you know who I am hope you sharpen
these enough
see wait
you know he'll come for you
I don't want enough cash to get out of
this place for good luck I'll find
dinner go go for the throat at the 180
limit watch
one way or another this is my last night
in Vegas
[__]
the serial killer on the loose
every day another officer down
[Music]
when the law can't protect its own you
need the man
who breaks all the rules yeah look at
the attacker all she could say for sure
is that it's bacon wine big and white so
it's not the blanket from Different
Strokes
we've got it
[Applause]
I want a lawyer and a sandwich
oh and I want to update my Facebook
status
he's covered his tracks we can't prove
anything
so spill and you're gonna take any notes
I look like I'll carry a pencil
Jason Statham
[Music]
estate Patty considine
Aidan Gillen
[Music]
picking the wrong fight let's pick the
right weapon
alerts
[Music]
thank you